if you were to tell me about Wikipedia
before Wikipedia was created I would
have laughed at the possibility of
something like that being possible just
a handful of folks can organize right
and self and moderate with a mostly
unbiased way the entirety of human
knowledge I mean so if there's something
like the approach that Wikipedia took
possible for mlms
uh that's really exciting I think that's
possible and in fact Wikipedia today is
still not today it's still not
deterministically correct right so you
cannot take to the bank right every
single thing on every single page but it
is probabilistically correct right and
specifically the way I describe
Wikipedia to people it is it is more
likely that Wikipedia is right than any
other source you're going to find yeah
it's this old question right of like
okay like are we looking for Perfection
um are we looking for something that
asymptotically approaches uh Perfection
are we looking for something that's just
better than the Alternatives and
Wikipedia right has exactly your point
has proven to be like overwhelmingly
better than than uh than people thought
and I think I I think that's where this
this ends and then underneath all this
is the fundamental question of uh where
you started which is okay what you know
what is truth how do we get the truth
how do we know what truth is and we live
in an era in which an awful lot of
people are very confident that they know
what the truth is and I don't really buy
into that and I think the history of the
last you know 2000 years or four
thousand years of human civilization is
actually getting to the truth is
actually a very difficult thing to do
are we getting closer if we look at the
entirety the Ark of human history are we
getting closer to the truth I don't know
okay is it possible is it possible that
we're getting very far away from the
truth because of the internet because of
how rapidly you can create narratives
and just as the entirety of a society
just move like crowds in a hysterical
way along those narratives that don't
have a necessary grounding in whatever
the truth is sure but like you know we
came up with Communism before the
internet somehow right like which was I
would say had rather larger issues than
anything we're dealing with today we had
in the way it was implemented at issues
and it's theoretical structure it had
like real issues did like a very deep
fundamental misunderstanding of human
nature and economics yeah but those
folks sure work very confident there was
the right way they were extremely common
and my point is they were very confident
3 900 years into what we would presume
to be Evolution towards the truth yeah
and so my my my assessment is my
assessment is number one there's no
there's no need for you know there's no
need for healing there's no need for the
hegelian dialectic to actually converge
towards the truth
like apparently not
um yeah so yeah so why we're so obsessed
with there being one truth is it
possible there's just going to be
multiple truth like little communities
that how they believe certain things and
I think it's now number one I think it's
just really difficult like who gets you
know historically who gets to decide
what the truth is it's either the king
or the priest right like and so we don't
live in an era anymore if kings were
priest dictating it to us and so we're
kind of on our own and so I I my my
typical thing is like we just we just
need a huge amount of humility um and we
need to be very suspicious of people who
claim that they have the capital yeah
and then we need we need to have I know
look the good news is The Enlightenment
has bequeathed us with a set of
techniques to be able to presumably get
closer to truth through the scientific
method and rationality and observation
and experimentation and hypothesis and
you know we need to continue to embrace
those even when they give us answers we
don't like sure but uh the internet and
technology has enabled us to uh generate
a large number of content
that data uh that the process the
scientific process allows us sort of
um damages the Hope Laden within the
scientific process because if you just
have a bunch of people saying facts
on the internet and some of them are
going to be llms
you how is anything testable at all
especially that involves like human
nature things like this there's a lot of
physics here's a question a friend of
mine just asked me on this topic so
suppose you had llms in equivalent of
gpt4 even five six seven eight suppose
you have them in the 1600s yeah and
Galileo comes up for trial yeah right
and you ask the llm like a Scala is
Galileo right yeah like what does it
answer right and one theory is it
answers no that he's wrong because the
overwhelming majority of human thought
up until that point was that he was
wrong and so therefore that's what's in
the training data yeah
um another way of thinking about it is
well it's officially Advanced llm will
have evolved the ability to actually
check the math right um and we'll
actually say actually no actually you
know you may not want to hear it but
he's right now if you know the church at
that time was you know owned the llm
they would have given it human you know
human feedback to prohibit it from
answering that question right and so I
like to take it out of our current
context because that like makes it very
clear those 10 questions apply today
right this is exactly the point of a
huge amount of the human feedback
training that's actually happening with
these LMS today this is a huge like
debate that's happening about whether
open source you know AI should be legal
or the the the actual mechanism of doing
the human RL with human feedback
is seems like such a fundamental and
fascinating question how do you select
the humans exactly
yeah how do you select a human AI
alignment right which everybody like is
like oh that sounds great alignment with
what human values
whose human values who's human values so
we're and we're in this mode of like
social and popular discourse where like
you know there's you know you see this
what do you think of when you read a
story in the Press right now and they
say you know XYZ made a baseless claim
about some topic right and there's one
group of people who are like aha think
you know they're doing fact checking
there's another group of people that are
like every time the Press says that it's
now a tech and that means that they're
lying right like
so like we're in this we're in this
social context where there's the the
level to which a lot of people in
positions of power have become very very
certain that they're in a position to
determine the truth for the entire
population is like there's like there's
like some bubble that has formed around
that idea and at least it flies
completely in the face of everything I
was ever trained about science and about
reason
um and Strikes me as like you know
deeply offensive um and incorrect